e
e e
seeing that it is uh 12:30 I will open
our Committee hearing this is uh
executive session on the four interim
study bills that we had um proper
motions for these will be either uh to
recommend future legislation or to not
recommend future
legislation um I'm going to actually
open the floor for a little discussion
sort of like a mini work session before
we get into the Motions on these um and
I'll start out that discussion by saying
that we did do a full study with the air
rifles for hunting game bill which is
the first on the list 1024 we actually
had a work session over the summer over
at Sig with a bunch of committee members
uh the department of fishing game and
the Commissioners from fishing game and
they all recommended uh the commission
and and the department recommended that
we pursue future legislation with their
guidelines and so that that legislation
has been submitted and I would request
kindly that the committee say that that
one should be found as recommended for
future legislation because both the
commission and the department are
interested in that um and then I will
open it up to anybody else who has wants
to discuss any of the bills that are in
front of us um before we get started on
the executive session part of it does
anybody have anything to say about any
of these uh these bills that are
listed including the one I just spoke
about okay I will add um one more bit
that I had in my notes
from 1530 FN require in Fish and Game
officers to wear body cameras uh there
was discussion from the Department on
that that if we were to pursue future
legislation it must be framed to have
funding given to the department to cover
the costs of all those and to have the
the uh law enforcement division of the
department draw a policy based on other
departments using body cameras so that
there's a clear policy in place as well
and I think that the first bill was
missing that kind of information so if
we are to recommend future legislation
for that we should make it clear that
the future legislation should include
funding and um and a a framework of of
policy um and given that it might be a
tough budget year it may not go anywhere
through Finance but that funding would
need to be a critical part of the
bill um and if there's nothing from
anybody else I'll open the floor to some
motions but um actually let's go around
and introduce each other because we've
got a new clerk we've got a sub so if
you'd like go down and do your names so
that he can get the names right for the
the roll calling and all that to make it
easier for
himan Lauren
Fox
J which one you looking for Mr Smith
went to
Washington where is
he oh there you are way up
there you got kofalt and then Harvey
kofalt
there representative Kimberly a bear
Mike
wette and of course
me okay got everybody thank you sir okay
so we'll open the floor to motions is
there a motion on um HB
1024 I recognize you m rep ulette I make
the motion that HB
1024 be U pursued in future legislation
recommended for future legislation
absolutely seconded by
kofalt any discussion on
that seeing none the clerk may call the
role okay representative
Smith yes representative CA yes
represent Tudor yes click votes yes
representative C yes representative
wette yes representative abai yes
representative jav yes representative of
fox yes and Mr chairman
yes I don't know if these go on consent
or not I think they're just final
reports we're not going to be meeting
again so they wouldn't be on the
floor so our report will reflect uh
unanimous um future
legislation I will
um Now open up for motion on 1148 which
is relative to the fishing Game
Commission representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman I'll make a
motion to not recommend this bill for
future
legislation okay the motion is not
recommend do we have a
second representative ulette
seconds any
discussion seeing none oh the okay I'm
sorry
um ex just explain the process to me a
little bit
um either
way future legislation can come back
absolutely thank you absolutely what we
do here today is just a a result of our
interim studies Andor discussions that
we've had amongst the committee and um
does not reflect on what somebody could
put in for future legislation because we
cannot bind a future legislation
legislature by our decision here so I'm
just confused about
um why do we even vote but that's okay
it's a technicality
okay in my view in my view it's in my
view it's ceremonially only in a waste
of
time I I that's what I was thinking but
I didn't want to say it out loud but
thank
[Laughter]
you okay the clerk may call the role
yes
yes again PL
yeses a ceremonious no
no
yes okay the report will reflect not
recommended for future legislation on
1148 I will open the floor now for a
motion on 1530 FN I'll make that motion
that um future Reg
future legislation is
needed okay do we have a second
second second did by a
bear any
discussion seeing none clerk may call
the
role representative Harvey made the
motion thank
you one thing I will point out while
he's getting ready for the role is that
we are supposed to write a little blurb
if we made the motion on the thing to go
on the
report and unless you would like to ask
somebody else for help in writing that
we just need to turn a blur bin with
this that says this is why we recommend
it future legislation
that um it needs to be finished by the
end of the month so if you if you gave
it to us by um end of the week I think
it would be
fine myself and and the uh assistant
who's going to be putting it
together our our committee
assistant yep
Jamie okay the clerk may call the
rle
yes yes
yes yes thank
you
yes
yes CH
yes motion
pass that will go on our report
reflected as future legislation is
recommended and final bill for the day
uh 1532 relative to the landowner rights
and responsibilities pertaining to game
cameras and tree stands this was the
bill that just allowed a land owner to
remove the game camera or tree stand
instead of requiring that the landowner
contact fishing game or law enforcement
to remove the game camera or tree stand
in the instances where they might just
be a neighbor they didn't want to get
involved with the law enforcement Etc
but um there was a lot of confusion as
to whether that was legal and all this
other stuff so the more investigation
needs to be done at the drafting stage
if legislation were to be recommended
um current law says that you you're as a
land owner if somebody puts a camera or
tree stand without your permission that
you have to contact law enforcement or
fishing game to have it removed by
them okay uh any discussion on or do I
have a motion on this one I I'll make
the motion that future legislation is
needed okay do we have a second second
that was moved by representative Harvey
and seconded by representative a a
bear any discussion on
this not seeing any the clerk may call
the role
yes
yes I'm sorry
yes yes passes 10 to Z
and again that will be reflecting future
legislation is
needed and and I was just going to get
to the reports that are due um it
doesn't have to be long a sentence or
two is all we need and if you could read
to me the people who made the Motions on
each of them I'll make sure that um they
know that they're responsible to give me
a report or a uh a a
uh 1532 with representative Harvey and a
be so representative Harvey would be the
report on that one uh then on 1530
representative
hary they're only going to be a sentence
or two and I'll have them to you by the
end of the day oh that's perfect thank
you uh 1148 is representative
Smith and 1024 is
representative you okay with that abely
all
right Mr chairman representative PL I
found this to be excruciating
Duty thank you for allowing me to serve
on fishing game you're very welcome I
will take this opportunity to thank all
of you for a successful and great year I
think that we did a fantastic job as a
committee I look forward to seeing
everybody again after the elections and
next year and next term uh unless you're
not running again um but
uh representative abar it's been a
pleasure serving with you and I I think
you're the only one who's not coming
back that I know of oh representative PL
the two of you uh fantastic serving with
you and I'm I'm sorry to not be serving
with you again next
year um with that we will close our
Committee hearing and I hope everybody
has a great rest of the day and uh good
luck in the elections
okay